dejar de ser cómplices de rusia en su
discurso ante los líderes mundiales en
la asamblea general de las naciones
unidas el presidente de francia el año
el macuf dijo que los países que todavía
no se habían alineado del lado de
ucrania cometían un error histórico los
que se callan hoy sirven a su pesar o
secretamente con cierta complicidad a la
causa de un nuevo imperialismo de un sí
mismo contemporáneo que está
desintegrando nuestro orden
internacional sin el cual la paz no es
posible y posible una visión compartida
por otra gran figura del bloque
occidental
olaf scholz quien aseguró que vladimir
putin debe reconocer que no puede ganar
la guerra para el canciller alemán
ayudar a ucrania es una cuestión de paz
global
estamos apoyando a ucrania con toda
nuestra fuerza financiera económica con
la ayuda humanitaria y también con armas
y es así como estamos cumpliendo una
promesa que todos y cada uno de los
países se hacen al ingresar a las
relaciones unidas a saber unir fuerzas
para mantener la paz y la seguridad
internacional
scholz también hizo un llamado a
reformar un organismo clave el consejo
de seguridad es del que rusia hace parte
el primer ministro de japón fungicida lo
apoya
la credibilidad de naciones unidas está
en juego debido a la agresión contra
ucrania por parte de rusia un miembro
permanente del consejo de seguridad
con los estados miembros la onu debe
actuar para restaurar la credibilidad de
esta organización
si bien rusia planea ganar territorios
con referendos en zonas ocupadas el
presidente de polonia 11 ayuda advierte
que para moscú la guerra ya está perdida
el agresor en cierto sentido ya ha
perdido ha perdido porque no ha logrado
someter a todas las naciones ha perdido
porque no ha roto el espíritu de la
nación ucraniana ha perdido porque no ha
dispersado al ejército ucraniano a pesar
de que la guerra en ucrania era una
cuestión inevitable muchas delegaciones
ya advirtieron quien no quieren que el
tema domina toda la asamblea frente a
otros retos importantes como la crisis
alimentaria global las crisis
migratorias y ante todo el cambio
climático